good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight you got to hand it to
the biden people
they don't specialize in subtlety you're
not going to miss the point when they
talk
and they've been talking a lot about
foreign policy for months the white
house has told us that if we're real
americans if we love this country and
aren't traitors quizlings
then we will wholeheartedly support
jumping with both feet into a highly
complicated conflict in an obscure part
of eastern europe where we have no
national interests
why
because ukraine's borders are sacred
unlike your own and if we're good people
we'll recognize that and not ask any
questions
so that's been their argument that you
may notice it's not actually an argument
it doesn't even approach an argument it
is a lecture it is delivered at high
volume with their signature freshman
year self-righteousness how dare you
no one from the biden white house is
actually trying to convince you of
anything they leave that for people they
care about like they're donors they're
not telling you that what happens in
ukraine is more important than what
happens in your own country though
obviously that's the underlying
assumption they certainly believe that
but they can't say it out loud they
rarely say anything they mean out loud
what they do and what they're doing now
is they just yell at you about
everything shut up paul
take the shot surrender that civil
liberty pledge allegiance to ukraine or
else you're a dangerous tool of vladimir
putin it's a heavy hand
this once again
is not subtle stuff not a light touch so
why do they do it well they do it
because it works
you can see it on display in washington
even in that supposedly divided city a
place you hear a lot about partisan
gridlock nothing gets done
well some things get done
you'll note that not a single republican
leader has stood up to point out how
insane all of this is and how completely
divorced it is from anything that
american voters actually care about
just the opposite if you listen to mitch
mcconnell the leader of the republicans
in the senate you would think that with
the average say welder back in his home
state of kentucky really wants more than
a pay raise or an affordable vacation or
decent schools for his children what he
really wants is an end to russian
aggression against the brave people of
eastern ukraine and that's why if you go
to any dollar store in the state from
ashland to covington to paducah to
owensboro you'll find what they used to
call regular folks muttering bitterly
about that damn vladimir putin
will he cross the naipa river on the way
to pervasque
how can zilenski stop him and are the
moldovans safe what about moldova's
territorial integrity that's what
they're talking about in kentucky
tonight
of course it's possible we haven't
run a poll or anything that some in
kentucky and in fact about 49 other
states might be wondering tonight about
gas prices and they have reason to
wonder the price of energy is about to
go up dramatically in this country
thanks to joe biden's adventurism in
eastern europe
so that's a news story too and our own
peter ducey asked about it today in the
white house briefing watch
gas in california is almost five dollars
a gallon should people across the
country expect to see that kind of a
number when they go to gas up their car
five dollars six dollars well again i
think as you heard the president say
last week uh standing up for our values
is not without cost
oh
that's the quote answer
standing up for our values is not
without cost school's the gender studies
major from oberlin college
fair enough
but that raises two questions what
exactly are our values
and what is the cost
now we can't answer the first question
with any precision though we're pretty
certain it has something to do with
trans rights how could it not those are
our values
as for the cost
what is the cost
well here's nbc news
the national average now the highest
since 2014 at 351 a gallon up 20 cents
in a month up 88 cents from a year ago
california with the tire gas taxes now
averaging 4.72 a gallon for 82 in the
bay area russia is the world's third
largest oil producer experts warn that
an invasion sanctions and counter
sanctions could push gas prices to an
all-time high i think that combined with
the seasonal ingredients would push the
national average up beyond the four
dollar gallon mark it's simply just a
matter of time potentially pushing six
dollars a gallon in california
six dollars a gallon oil tonight
approaching a hundred dollars a barrel
long as it's been
that high in a long time
so that's not a small thing and it
doesn't just apply to you if you drive a
car if you purchase
any physical object
it's almost certain that object had to
be driven to you by someone who burns
gasoline so the price of everything is
about to rise and in a country that just
beneath the surface is a lot poorer than
it looks that's not a small thing in
fact it's going to be a tragedy for a
lot of people a legitimate tragedy so if
you cared about the people you governed
that would not be something you'd blow
off with a flip of the hand as the cost
of our values you'd care
what you certainly wouldn't do if you
wanted to preserve domestic stability is
make it very very obvious you don't care
at all
and yet that's exactly what they're
doing they're telling you right to your
face we don't care
watch this guy on cnn
will there be economic additional
economic pressure on americans and
people around the world if we stand up
to aggression yes but what the sacrifice
that's being
requested from people potentially to
defend democracy and the liberal
international order that has brought in
75 years of peace and prosperity in
europe something unprecedented in the
wake of world war ii that america and
its allies helped build
um
we we need to remember that we are not
fragile things that we're not as
churchill said made of sugar candy that
dealing with a little bit of difficulty
to stand down authoritarianism and
autocracy is not too much to ask we need
to straighten and stiffen our spines a
little bit
oh we quoted churchill he's wearing a
spread collar he must be on to something
he's channeling one of the great leaders
of the anglosphere winston churchill
a couple questions how are we defining
liberal democracy how are we defining
international order how are we defining
sacrifice none of those terms are ever
defined but it's the last one that they
spend the least amount of time on
sacrifice because of course the
sacrifice will be yours it will not be
theirs the person you just saw speaking
lives in a duplex in new york city was
once owned by the astor family we know
that because he invited a new york times
reporter and a photographer into his
home to brag about how rich he is
there's nothing wrong with being rich
but if you are it's probably unwise
to give the back of the hand to people
who aren't and to tell them yes you're
getting a lot poorer but that's okay
because it'll make me feel better about
myself
that posture over time is more corrosive
of social cohesion in fact of democracy
than maybe any other and history is
littered with fallen regimes that have
proved that
let them eat cake
so even at cnn whose shows are not
anchored by geniuses and even on this
show which is anchored by the
former morning zoo host from tacoma
what that guy just said seemed a little
much and so she said so watch this it's
interesting
that's a lot to ask how do p how are you
expecting people to focus on democracy
when the kitchen table issues are eating
them up
well i think two things about that bre
you're right obviously people are
feeling a lot of difficulty but that's
also where government can take action to
alleviate some short-term stress and i
know folks are tired i know they're
frustrated but what we're being asked to
do what we've been asked to do is far
less than other generations have been
asked to do
what are you talking about son we're
being asked to do by whom by the
ukrainians the people who paid off joe
biden's family we're being asked to who
do you think you are
to lecture a country of 340 million
people in this way sure you won't be
able to go on vacation with your family
this summer sure
the staples that you use every single
day may be out of reach
but it's not a big deal because dunkirk
imagine
but it's not just that guy that dim bulb
lecturing us about how the sacrifice is
worth it
it's virtually everyone in power now
what basis is it worth it well they all
have the same line it's not rehearsed or
anything
they're telling us that being able to
defend democracy
our great privilege will make all the
suffering worth it
watch
the reality is that this is a moment
where we will have to experience uh some
short-term pain in order to make very
clear
uh that putin cannot invade ukraine with
impunity yes there is likely to be a
cost exactly what that cost is going to
be
will be
in the pockets of the americans there's
no doubt about that my point to people
here at home
is you can expect gas prices to go up
you can expect food costs to go up
and i can tell you from history
anytime we sit silent
and
watch the rights of one group
be eviscerated it's just a matter of
time that comes back to haunt
us it's a little calling to be lectured
by people with impossibly generous
congressional pensions about sacrifices
that you get to make
but it's especially infuriating to hear
the last guy who's speaking of food
prices has skipped very few meals
recently
tell you that looking at history informs
you of everything you need to know about
the future really what sort of history
are we talking about how about last year
when the withdrawal from afghanistan
humiliated degraded and weakened this
country
did lindsey graham supposedly cares
about the military do a single thing to
improve it did he call for the
resignation of any person responsible
for that humiliating disaster that
resulted in the deaths of american
citizens no he didn't
and those same people are now in charge
of our strategy in ukraine
so you could call that history and it
might be worth learning from it and one
of the things you learn is the people
currently in charge have an extensive
and easily verifiable track record of
failure
when they intervene
into the highly complex affairs of other
countries countries whose languages they
don't speak and whose histories they
don't understand
people who by hubris and boredom
wind up interjecting themselves into
places they know nothing about
but the bigger question really for
lindsey graham is when is the last time
he did anything
one thing to improve the life of an
american citizen
other than himself
gas prices have go up food prices are
good well that's okay because it won't
affect lindsey graham he doesn't have
kids and he's got that generous
congressional pension he's set
but what about you
well you're going to be repaid in virtue
now it's not cash
it's not even cryptocurrency
it's better
for the rest of your life you can feel
good about having supported something
called democracy something that is in
shorter supply in this country than it's
ever been but something that we hope to
defend in a country you can't identify
on a map
so you may be poor in fact it's almost
certain that you will be but you can be
very proud of that and by the way if you
don't do that you're a murderer here's
our daily reminder from mr alexander
vindeman a ukrainian on msnbc
but when you have tens of thousands of
casualties
the republicans are going to own it
tucker carlson is going to own this
he's basically digging his own grave
so to speak his political grave it is
going to be a meat grinder and he just
went on record tucker carlson donald
trump basically encouraging this i think
this is the beginning of the end of
these you know completely avatar
far-right
uh whack jobs
that are basically encouraging
putin to take us action
so it turns out it's not vladimir putin
who's invading ukraine
it's the republicans
it's donald trump and the fox news talk
shows
they're invading ukraine and snuffing
out democracy now why do we play that
why we give that guy air time because
it's just interesting to check in on the
hysteria levels just how floored are
they how red in the face and crazed are
they
well they're at 11 this week and that
tells you something any criticism at all
any question
at all evokes that kind of performance
why is it in america's interest to do
this that seems like a fair question
shut up your hitler
and we're not overstating it by the way
before we play this next clip from nancy
pelosi still speaker of the house
it tells you a lot
if you respond to a
question like how does this help us
by accusing the person who asked the
question of evil motives
of working for satan or worse
you're probably not coming from a
position of strength
strong people are calm
they know what they think
they know why they're doing what they're
doing they know how to convince you to
support them in that
people who know they're wrong who are
doing something that they don't want
revealed in public become hysterical and
so these people are hysterical
as promised here's nancy pelosi
this is a very
evil move on the part
of vladimir putin he's a kgb guy who
happens to be probably the richest man
in the world because of his exploitation
of his own people that he doesn't want
them to know about this my friends is
our moment
this is the sudan line that's what
people were saying there
it's our moment
it's the dayton land
oh you catch that oh so it's a nazi
thing
like everything else they don't like
truck drivers are nazis trump voters are
nazis anyone who opposes election fraud
is a nazi got it that's the template
always
but it's kind of a weird template not to
get too literal or anything to apply in
this circumstance since technically it
was russia that fought the nazis and
more than any other country beat them
just just saying
while it was ukraine that collaborated
with the nazis hmm
that doesn't mean they're doing it now
but as long as we're pulling out the
historical references
that's true
now you think nancy pelosi would know
that she was actually alive at the time
believe it or not nancy pelosi was born
before the second world war even started
but whatever all bad things are nazi
things
and all good things are democracy things
watch
i think the one thing that we all agreed
upon the attack on the ukraine by the
russians is an attack
on democracy putin is terrified by the
prospect of a democracy at his border
and that's why defending democracy both
at home and abroad must be an urgent
national security priority what is our
democracy worth
if we're not able and willing to stand
against an invasion of another democracy
so you you just got to play the clip of
the last guy with his his weird scraggly
beard always always looks like he's
reading something but can't quite
pronounce the words
anyway it's about democracy now we've
told you night after night not because
we're anti-ukraine or pro-russia or
agnostic on both don't live in either
country don't plan to don't care to
it's not a matter of
preferring one over the other
it's just a stubborn insistence on
defining words accurately
because they matter in this country if
you subvert the meaning of a word as
fundamental as democracy
maybe you can tamper with the way we
live here in the united states just
spitballing for a second
so ukraine to be technical is not a
democracy democracies don't arrest
political opponents and they don't shut
down opposition media both of which
ukraine has done and by the way ukraine
is a pure client state
of the united states state department
again that's fine we're not mad about
that go ahead and run ukraine if you
want if you can do a better job than
ukrainians just don't tell us its
democracy
but as long as the core goal of american
foreign policy is to defend democracy
and oppose anyone who's not running a
democracy you got to kind of wonder and
this may be occurring to these countries
what about our friends in jordan
in qatar
and saudi arabia
what about at least 50 countries in
africa none of which is a democracy
are they in trouble too
are we sending advanced weapon systems
from raytheon to topple those
non-democracies just on principle are
those the values we're defending as we
live through higher inflation and higher
gas prices and gets steadily poorer
would also be interesting to know
if the people you just saw blowing about
democracy are as exercised by china's
lack of democracy
if china ever moves against taiwan when
we get the same lectures
oh probably not
the democratic party's donors have grown
rich from the chinese non-democracy in
other words the dictatorship nancy
pelosi's family has grown rich from that
dictatorship so don't expect to hear
nancy pelosi compare chairman g to
hitler anytime soon
look debates about what is or what is
not a democracy are interesting and they
may have some academic importance but in
the face of the material reality
of life in the united states for example
how much do things cost can i afford
them does the plane land on time does it
land safely can i take the subway or am
i going to get stabbed by a mental
patient somebody let out onto the street
those are the realities that actually
matter not just in this country but in
every country
and the very people pushing this
defensive democracy are the very people
who've made those material realities
much worse in this country
and until they answer for that
if they shouldn't move on to another
country try to improve things there
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else